if the only place left you call home has
been invaded by horrifying titans what
would you do these terrifying creatures
are invading your city killing your
friends and family and it's up to you to
stop them i'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the horrifying titans in attack
on titan season two these kids have no
idea that some of them are about to be
ripped apart by flesh-eating titans this
young group of scouts sit and waste the
days away within the walls of this
garrison and they all wonder what the
hell they are doing here the fight is
out there not here and one of them even
thinks about sneaking away to go check
on his family that lives in a nearby
village but that's when they get word
that titans have breached the wall yet
again and this head scout leader tells
these rookies to go alert all of the
nearby towns telling them to evacuate
now and these guys prepare to die for
their home all over again but this guy's
mustache means that he's in charge and
he leads everybody away from the titans
telling them to avoid all combat and
escape as he dives head first into
battle to give them more time okay this
is absolutely horrifying these scouts
were ill-prepared and stood no chance to
stop the horde of flesh-eating monsters
they literally had no choice but to
avoid the fight option 1 using their
horses which are bred to be faster than
a titan they run and hide within the
nearby trees but only hiding in the
trees that are taller and bigger than
the titans chasing them or option 2 they
ignore orders and stay to help mustache
warrior and hide within the building
itself and then flee in the early
morning hours when most of the titans
around would be more dormant and would
have given the group an easier time in
getting away assuming they survived the
night both options are risky however as
the guardians of the land within these
walls their duty demands that they must
warn the citizens of a titan invasion
but if this was the case they should
have planned it better and should have
implemented some sort of primitive alarm
system they could have warned the public
of the invasion more quickly and
effectively than simply sending
messengers to each individual town
because this is not only slow and
ineffective but as you saw that means no
scouts were able to stay behind to help
mustache warrior because they all had to
spread the word obviously they don't
have cell phones or two-way radio
technology to warn everyone and this
problem shouldn't be too huge of an
issue to solve because primitive alarm
systems have been in use for a millennia
and have taken various forms throughout
history from the use of animals such as
dogs geese and livestock placed around
areas to vocalize when trouble was
nearby to even alarm bells being
signaled by scouts placed within towers
and this is one example of an alarm
system that this city could have built
bells by design are loud as hell and one
example of how loud they can be can be
found in the east end district of london
a church known as bow church these bells
can be heard when rung throughout the
entire borough of hackney london which
is over 4.5 miles away from where bow
church is if sound can roughly travel
one mile every five seconds not taking
into account temperature and humidity
this means that the sounds coming from a
bell will be able to reach 4.5 miles
away in about 4.5 seconds or 20 miles in
22.5 seconds even the fittest trained
endurance horses at most can travel 20
miles in one and a half hours now i'm
not saying that normally alarm bells can
be heard 20 miles away but you get my
point using horses as a means of an
alert system was inefficient to begin
with because these guys can only alert
everyone in the far away towns as fast
as their horses can take them which
isn't nearly as fast as the speed of
sound obviously the citizens of this
place should have built scout towers
around the perimeter of all the walls as
well as all over the land with an
average gap between towers of about 4
miles making sure that each tire would
ring at the first sound heard from the
bells being rung closest to the wall
which would then create a sort of domino
effect where the bell sound would travel
all the way to the towns intended in a
much shorter time frame this means that
at the very first sighting of a titan
citizens and towns of miles away could
have been informed of this within
minutes of the titans being spotted
another method could have been how
pippin led the signal beacon to call on
rohan for help in the lord of the rings
return of the king by using signal
beacons to alert each tower one by one
to inform the intended town of any
incoming threats because they didn't
have any pre-installed alarm system of
any sort considering how big of a
problem titans are was a huge mistake to
begin with this mustache warrior is the
second top dog in the unit second only
to captain levi in skill and kills off
titan after titan until only four remain
suddenly he comes across the most
horrifying thing ever this beast titan
and it can speak and this monster steals
his gear and leaves him to beg for his
life as the rest of the hungry titans
eat him alive elsewhere back at the main
city they've just gone through hell
trying to save themselves from this
female titan taking her away to
experiment on her but they don't realize
that this is only the beginning of more
terrifying things to come and this group
suddenly spots a titan within the walls
of their decimated city and this priest
orders them to keep their mouths shut
and to keep that titan out of sunlight
horrifying everybody here to the bone up
until now almost no one knew what these
darn near indestructible walls were made
of and the glasses girl interrogates the
[ __ ] out of this priest but he says
nothing even with a threat of her
dropping him from the top of the wall
and this makes her think that all of
these walls are made out of titan flesh
elsewhere half human half titan hybrid
aaron sits resting along with his
longtime friend mikasa as they try and
recover from the female titan's wrath
that recently wrecked havoc on the city
but suddenly they get word along with
everybody else the titans have breached
the walls nearby these guys then head
off to fight the titans coming from the
breach within wall rose but on the way
glasses girl thinks that because aaron
is half human half titan they make a
plan for aaron to use his titan body to
somehow fill the hole from within the
gate but there's no guarantee that he'll
be able to do it but he has no choice if
they don't close the wall soon thousands
more titans will come through and
everybody will die meanwhile the
survivors of mustache warriors group
reach their hometown to warn everybody
of the incoming titans but something is
not right as this kid sees his village
already destroyed but with no bodies in
sight no bodies except for this one
fallen titan and it directly speaks to
him saying welcome home freaking this
kid out to his core right before this
officer tells them to keep on moving in
the middle of the night in total
darkness this group of scouts rides
close along the wall rose to find
exactly where the breach is but they
eventually run into this other group of
scouts meaning they've come full circle
and no one has found the breach within
the wall and no one knows how the titans
got in freaking everyone out and they
decide to rest for the night in an
abandoned military post nearby back with
aaron and his crew they prepare to ride
out into titan territory to stop the
incoming titans but glasses girl again
tries to find out what this priest knows
about the titan within the wall and he
finally tells her that a girl within the
scout regiment named christa is the key
to the titan wall secret and that they
need to find her as soon as possible
aaron then realizes that her group is
already out on the front lines where the
titans are which means they need to find
her now but it's too late because that's
when the group of scouts back at the
abandoned military outpost realized
they've just been found by titans the
veterans within the group tell the
rookies to hide within the castle tower
and they jump off of the top of the
tower to fight these flesh-eating beasts
head-on okay this is freaking nuts and
because of these scouts stupidity we are
now screwed it was clear that while
checking the wall earlier the moon was
being covered by the clouds which caused
everything around them to be almost
pitch black with the moon coming and
going throughout the night this is what
allowed the titans to surprise these
scouts right outside their tower in the
first place because with the moon being
covered out there these scouts couldn't
see [ __ ] but then this makes them look
so stupid because if you look at where
they are located what is the one thing
that basically advertised their location
at that castle tower for the titans to
see it was their lit fire the only light
source at the top of that tower with a
360 degree view of everything and unless
something or someone got real close the
scouts sitting next to the fire couldn't
see anything anyways they were begging
to have a problem and all the titans
anywhere nearby could come and see their
stupid flame because the deeper the
darkness the brighter the light now it's
not clear up to this point how good the
eyesight of titans are however a healthy
human eye on average will be able to see
a lit candle flame as far as 1.6 miles
away if there aren't any obstructions in
the way and these idiots felt the need
to light up their location at the tower
just like a lighthouse their mission was
to find the breach in the wall they had
to wait until early morning anyways
before they could move on they had no
reason to blast out their location as
much as they did they should have had a
group keep watch at the top of the tower
and if they're worried about getting
cold then they can just bundle up deal
with it and have two man shifts rotating
out every 20 to 30 minutes at a time
also from the moment that they left the
garrison the rookies should have been
given back their odm gear this would
have doubled their attack power and
increases their chances of survival
because now the titans are here and only
the scout veterans have their odm gear
killing off a handful of titans will be
more than possible for them but it will
not do much to stop the overall horde
coming this way and the fact that we're
in well-known titan territory means that
killing all of these monsters is likely
going to bring even more attention to
ourselves and we also just noticed that
random time passes by it's something
we've never seen before which means we
shouldn't bring more attention to
ourselves at this point because we don't
know what we're dealing with and the
capabilities of that giant titan making
him a wild card this is one instance
where the veterans need to sacrifice
themselves and draw the titans away from
the tower and into the forests leaving
the rookies inside now this place looks
like it is made out of stone and will
usually be built directly on rock or
have substantial foundations built
underneath the castle to support the
overall structure of the foundation the
inclusion of having substantial
foundations to support the overall
structure usually means that there's a
decent chance for a large basement
underneath it and coupled with the fact
that this place was built on flat land
increases the odds that there is a
basement of some sort that the rookies
can use to hide in because retreating to
enclosed spaces away from the titan's
line of sight will be one way that they
can survive at least for a little while
so i would order a portion of the scout
rookies to make this their top priority
in finding out if there is a basement
once the basement is found i am ordering
all of the rookies to head down into the
basement and arm themselves as best as
they can this will allow them to
concentrate their attack onto one spot
and not get surrounded by titans because
they'll have to go through one entrance
way in order to get to them at best this
will allow us to take out most of the
horde while minimizing attention being
brought to ourselves since we'll be
leading the titans deeper underground to
get to us outside the veterans kill
every single titan bastard that comes
their way slicing and dicing bloody body
parts beautifully but back inside titans
have broken into the tower climbing up
the stairs to the terrified rookies this
dad rhino tries to block the door
struggling and wrestling with this
cannibal demon just before his bud
berthold and the rest of the rookies
help him out by crashing a literal
cannon into it but just then another
titan sneaks up and tries to eat this
kid but raina protects him letting it
tear into his arm while carrying it up
the stairs he's going to jump out of the
window taking the titan down along with
him but just at the last moment the rest
of the rookies managed to kick it off of
him having it fall to its death krista
then tense to rhina's wounds and her
kind actions turn him on a little too
much they realize that the scouts
fighting outside won't be able to hold
out much longer suddenly a massive rock
comes hurtling through the sky and
crashes into their horses while a second
one comes flying in and crashes into the
top of the tower killing the other two
veterans and they all see dozens more
titans incoming and they all start to
think that these titan tactics are way
too good and they suspect that this
beast titan that they just saw earlier
outside is somehow ordering this attack
from a distance meanwhile the last of
the scouts die a gruesome death as more
titans surround the castle tower ready
to peel the flesh off of these guys's
bones justin this girl yamir borrows a
knife and jumps off of the top of the
tower plunging herself down into a sea
of monsters as she injures her hand and
turns into a titan this shocks everyone
including raina and bertolt who realize
that this titan is the same one who ate
their friend out in the wild years ago
meaning that ymir is a murderer and the
group starts to wonder whether she's a
friend or a foe okay this is some wiggly
diggity type [ __ ] and now our closest
ally is another one of those monster
cannibal freaks now these kiddos up
until now have seen ymir for a while and
from the looks of things it seems like
she is trustworthy but that's exactly
what we thought of the female titan
earlier and she was batshit insane which
means we can't trust all of her actions
however the one thing that will be
harder to hide will be yamir
subconscious tendencies that she's
displayed so far and by observing these
we'll be better able to understand
yamir's overall character and mindset
but to do this we'll have to observe the
little things because while the tongue
may lie the nuances and subtleties in
someone's character is often far harder
to mask and it's these subtle examples
that will provide some direct insight
into someone's character telltale signs
can easily be found at how someone takes
food at a buffet or a military canteen
do they always take a lot of food do
they take the last bit of food not
caring if there will be enough for the
next person or do they tend to have
one-sided conversations lack perspective
don't reciprocate effort or frequently
demean and intimidate and bully others
these are the subtle signs of someone
that is self-centered and if we stop and
think we'll be able to remember that
from what we've seen of ymir thus far
it's clear that she naturally is selfish
cynical uncooperative and
confrontational now all of these traits
at first seem not that great this could
also mean that as a self-centered person
we could entice yamir to properly join
our side if she gets what she wants as
it's safe to assume that a self-centered
person will only care to look out for
themselves negating the possibility that
ymir could be entirely on the titan's
side if she is not getting what she
wants out of them so if we can find out
what she truly wants this could be our
way to lure her into joining our side at
least temporarily we don't have to be
best friends we just have to prove that
keeping us alive will benefit her more
than if she decides to kill us and join
the titans because remember we don't
know what she knows nor whose side she's
really on at least yet and for starters
this means i would keep a close watch on
krista and make sure that she doesn't
leave our site because she is the one
person who ymir is seemingly taking a
liking to so far now with all this being
said i still wouldn't waste time just
standing around twiddling our thumbs
because trying to convince yamir to join
our side is our last resort which means
these folks shouldn't sit around and
they should start moving because trying
to escape while ymir keeps these titans
busy will give us the time that we need
to get away if by some miracle there are
a few horses that haven't been crushed
yamir's jaw titan form kills and
slaughters the other titans but she
eventually gets pinned down and begins
to get eaten alive until krista screams
at her to destroy the tower instead she
breaks free from the titan mob and
begins destroying the tower making it
fall on the rest of the titans before
she saves the rest of the scouts telling
them to grab on to her hair as the tower
comes crashing down but nothing can stop
these abominations and suddenly they
burst out of the rubble and pineamir's
titanformed down and the scout rookies
can do nothing but look on in sheer
horror but suddenly aaron and his crew
arrive to save ymir and the rookies but
in the horrifying process ymir gets
badly injured the scouts retreat to the
top of the wall to recover as krista
tries to convince everybody that yamir
is a good guy but glasses girl is
skeptical as hell because if they're
wrong she might just be the next
horrifying female titan all over again
and she discusses with mikasa what they
told aaron the night before about a
horrifying secret involving one of the
soldiers in front of us because nearby
after all this bloodbath raina finally
cracks and confesses to aaron the most
insane secret ever the secret that
glasses go aaron and everybody else
already suspected for a while and he
tells aaron to join him because rhina
admits to aaron that he is in fact the
armored titan and mentions that bertolt
is the colossal titan the titans who
broke the wall after 100 years of peace
and the ones who caused aaron's mother's
death and mentions that their mission is
the extinction of mankind itself aaron
tries to keep his cool but at the last
minute his calm face breaks and reiner
spots this mikasa lunges in for the kill
but it's no use and this causes the two
to begin the most insane titan
transformation in history and these two
former scouts reveal their true
horrifying titan forms and everybody
prepares for battle yet again okay this
is some diagonally cut peanut butter on
toast type crap what glasses girl told
aaron the night before was that these
two titan transformers raina and bertolt
came from the same area as the female
titan and were close with her growing up
despite the fact that they almost never
spoke to each other during training or
at the academy and in trying to take
down the female titan earlier glasses
girl thinks that these two dudes passed
on information to the female titan and
that's how she found aaron in the first
place now knowing all of this
circumstantial evidence makes it a
little surprising how they left aaron
alone long enough for him to mess up and
get discovered by these two guys because
if we have to operate on probabilities
it was quite probable that bertolt and
rhina would have needed aaron to some
degree whether they would have needed
him to join forces with them or take him
out as the only allied titan member of
the scouts as their only trump card
aaron was most likely the target for
bert holt and rhino to confront and
these scouts should have done their
darnest to try and keep him apart from
those two because knowing about their
terrifying secret was their only trump
card and if they cleverly and purposely
kept aaron away from these two whether
that would have been by pretending to
reprimand aaron taking him away or
forcing him on an expedient mission away
from this location the scouts could have
kept up the illusion that these two
titans were still leading them on they
rushed it and got sloppy and this is
what led aaron to getting discovered
which makes sense because this guy is a
terrible liar also mikusa knows that
rhina is the better fighter and even
then she failed to take reiner out hell
the distance that she was when rhino was
discovered was unnecessary because
knowing what she knew she should have
been on rhino's ass nearby from the
start these two titans explode into
existence along with an enraged titan
form eren and the scouts can do nothing
but watch as the colossal titan throws
ymir right into its mouth they try to
kill it but it's no use because this
monster unleashes waves of scolding hot
steam that shields itself from the
scouts and with no way to kill it they
wait out its defenses as they watch
aaron fight the horrifying armored titan
head on mikasa tries to slice open the
nape of its neck it tightens one
weakness but her blades break instantly
getting absolutely pummeled by the
armored titan aaron thinks fast
utilizing grappling and submission
techniques he brings the armored titan
down to the ground pinning the armored
titan into submission and breaks off its
entire arm the armored titan gets up and
then expels some of its armor becoming
much lighter and faster which gives
mikasa a clue as to how to defeat it
cutting the weak points at the titan's
joints in between the armor she quickly
gets to work and slices the armor's
titan's weak points and helps out and
weaken it just enough for him to grapple
it down onto the ground again but this
time he doesn't let go and begin
squeezing the life right out of it like
there's no tomorrow but that's when
these scouts witness the most horrifying
trick ever because the armored tine
shifts outer nearer to the wall as he
yells out for the colossal titan to help
and the colossal titan comes crashing
down onto aaron himself and the two
monsters kidnap aaron's body by tearing
it from his titan form and leaves
everyone injured and beaten down
escaping off into the forest okay this
has officially become the biggest
crapshoot since the 2022 oscars but this
battle from the get-go was flawed aaron
is the most important tactical asset
that the scouts have and they should
have protected him better glasses girl
should have left one group to keep
berthold busy and then order the rest of
the entire scout squad to attack rhino
along with aaron because bertolt
probably can't keep up this steam power
forever and then it would be three to
four people versus one while the rest of
the scouts and aaron take on rhina if i
was glasses girl i would observe that
the colossal titan's armor does not
cover every square inch of its body
there are exposed areas where the plates
of armor do not touch i would order all
of my scouts to attack these spots in
coordination with aaron's attacks which
to be brutally honest kind of sucked
aaron from what we saw simply threw
haymakers like he had all the time in
the world despite the fact that each of
his punches didn't do [ __ ] and while
grappling was a solid move on his part
this was risky as hell because it meant
getting close to this dude while he had
a chance to lay one if not more strikes
on him and this guy's clearly a striker
and the better fighter because i mean
look at this guy he's literally built
like a brick [ __ ] house and since aaron
was fighting out in the open and in not
any type of confined space this means
that the striker aka the armored titan
had way more of a chance at beating him
where he stood by having the scouts
assist and keep the armored titan busy
this would allow aaron to do what he
should have done aaron is a human titan
hybrid just like rhino and bert holt
which means that he would have been
familiar with managing his energy
expenditure as a large animal and in
terms of energy metabolism the bigger
the animal the more energy they expend
now while larger animals like elephants
and presumably these titans have adapted
to having lower metabolic rates which
essentially means that even though they
use up more energy they're also more
efficient at managing their energy but
even then this still means that aaron
could have played this to his advantage
choosing to antagonize and evade
possible strikes that the armored titan
threw at him eventually making him use
of all of his energy because titan or
not striking in general uses up a lot of
energy because just minutes before we
saw reiner ask aaron to join him which
means that we already knew that this guy
would not leave until he caught us and
this means that aaron could have taken
his time with this battle and should
have taken advantage of the armored
titans conditioning because like in
combat sports he should have tried to
gas out his opponent this is the reason
why boxers and mixed martial artists
focus so much on conditioning over
strength because while being able to
throw any volume of strikes without
succumbing to fatigue is important
forcing the armored time to throw
punches all day at us would have meant
that we would have tired him out and
made him deplete any energy that he
would have had making it even easier for
the scouts and aaron to take him down
and have aaron subdue the armored titan
with the grappling techniques hours
later the rest of the squad recovers
from the terrifying events that just
happened as mikasa awakens in fright and
armin tells her that aaron has been
kidnapped and they're waiting for
reinforcements and horses before they
can go after him causing everyone to be
all droopy and sad as balls but this guy
tells everybody to cheer up but says
that aaron is a fighter and this totally
not paraphrased line motivates the [ __ ]
out of these two along with the rest of
the recovered squad who now declare
raina and bertolt to be enemies of the
state which means they won't stop
chasing them until they are captured
injured glasses girl then tells the
squad that she suspects that the two
titans are already exhausted and have
likely have taken a break nearby to
recharge their titan abilities which
means that while they rest these scouts
still have a chance to get them but she
mentions that they've headed deep into
titan territory an area swarming with
horrifying flesh-eating titans and warns
everybody that they might not make it
back home because what lies ahead of
these scouts is truly terrifying the
group suits up and heads out to save
aaron and capture these two titans
meanwhile aaron finally wakes up badly
damaged along with ymir in the same boat
as him he looks up and sees an exhausted
rhina and bertolt who have taken their
odm gear and tells them that they're too
damaged to turn into titans and that
they're surrounded by titans below them
just waiting for the chance to eat them
making the possibility of escaping
impossible raina then says that they
have a plan to take these two back to
their hometown during the night when
most of the titans will not be as active
eren gets enraged and threatens to kill
them all but rhina tells him to save his
breath because he's gonna need it okay
right now we're in some deep [ __ ] aaron
and ymir aren't safe it's just them
against rhino bertolt and the titans
right below them just waiting for the
chance to tear them apart and use their
bones as toothpicks it's unlikely
they're ever going to make it out of
this forest alive with so many titans
nearby aaron has stumped for hands yamir
is injured and we don't have any horses
right now as much as it sucks we only
have one thing on our side potentially
and that's yamir because rhino and
bertolt are currently the only ones with
odm gear but they're out of energy and
aren't able to turn into titans and
knowing the importance of aaron and how
much the scouts value him it's beyond
certain that the scouts will be looking
for him which means we don't need to run
but simply by time i would try and
convince yamir to join our side for
starters since she at the moment is more
capable than us and again she isn't
loyal to any one person as long as she
gets what she wants rhina as well is
clearly the one with temper issues and
seems to be a little mentally fragile so
i think it wouldn't be impossible to
piss him off to the point that he tries
to come close to show us who's boss and
once he gets close enough this is when
we could try and tag tame it with ymir
subduing him enough to either we steal
his odm gear or get his gear off of him
and throw it down towards the titans and
even if bertolt still has his odm gear
by the end of this he won't be able to
save everyone meaning we'll have
effectively trapped everyone here buying
us more time until the scouts come to
rescue us as aaron loses his [ __ ] yamir
chimes in and mentions that she thinks
the beast titan from earlier is the one
who's responsible for the recent titan
infestation she and aaron didn't notice
reina starting to talk and act weird to
the point that they realize he's
developed almost a split personality
he's been undercover serving as a
soldier for so long he doesn't know
whose side he's on anymore but bertolt
tells him to cool it and he suddenly
snaps back to normal like a true psycho
ryana then tells yamir to join their
side and that they'll forgive her for
eating their friend years ago and
mentions that if she joins them she'll
rescue her close friend krista to keep
her safe making this a tough deal to
turn down so she accepts and suddenly
they then all see in the distance green
smoke which means the scouts are closing
in bert hold and rhino then beat up
aaron and try to escape with the two but
in the madness yamir sees krista in the
distance within the scouts and she tells
raina that now's their chance to save
her but rana tells her that they'll come
back later for her as in their current
condition they're not strong enough to
take on all of the scouts but ymir's got
some sweet [ __ ] between krista and her
and forces birdhold to crash telling
these two scout traders that her titan
form is meant for this environment and
that if she turns on them they won't be
able to stop her she demands that if
they want her to join their side they're
going to need to rescue krista now or
else and so the two are forced to agree
as the scouts begin to close in they
notice something is not right because
bertholdt and raina are nowhere to be
found only yamir and this skinhead dude
asks what she's doing just hanging
around on a tree but that's when arnon
notices that ymir is looking around for
someone and he sees her spot crista but
before he can do anything yamir snatches
up krista and eats her and she makes a
run for it meeting back up with
bertholdt and raina nearby and ryana
turns back into the armored titan and
helps all of them escape from the scouts
forcing mikasa to stand by and watch in
the distance okay we now have a real
problem because now our worst enemy has
all of our trump cards but the one thing
i don't get is why they let arguably the
second most important person there aside
from aaron near the front lines i'm
talking about crystal or historia if you
prefer based on what happened when we
discovered that yamir was a titan it was
painfully obvious how close krista was
to yamir based on how she was talking to
her on the tower and skinhead was the
only person who was present at the tower
and now is riding with the scouts
meaning he should have relayed this
information to the scouts beforehand
it's unclear exactly whose side ymir is
on however based on how alert the city
must have been from the disaster of the
female titan they should have never
trusted ymir to begin with and used as
much caution with her as they did when
they first found out that eren was a
titan this means that they should have
found a way to use christa as bait on
the off chance that ymir turned out to
be against them because without aaron
krista is the only thing they had left
to lure ymir in now nothing may come
from this as we saw that rhina didn't
even want to go back for her however
bringing her along as a plus one when we
literally had dozens of scouts already
as backup makes no sense and in reality
they should have kept krista away from
the front lines in the first place this
tactic would have likely forced ymir to
stay with us and would have forced rhina
and bertolt to abandon ymir entirely in
order to not get caught you'd think
after the female titan fiasco that these
guys would have learnt their lesson by
now helpless as aaron gets taken away
the scouts rush like hell to get aaron
back because the future of humanity
rests in his hands suddenly titans
behind them show up and start charging
after them they can't turn back
meanwhile on the armored titan yamir
spits krista out and she reacts in shock
that her best friend is siding with the
enemy but yamir pops out and tells her
that she needs to come with them
otherwise they'll both be killed and
that they will never be truly safe from
the horrors of the titans within their
city but krista thinks she's crazy and
tells her that she will always be her
friend and that it's not too late to
turn back but suddenly the [ __ ] show
begins the scouts catch up and try
swiping eren from berthold's grip mikasa
slices ymir's eye as the armored titan
shields berthold and eren within its
hands and the rest of the scouts try to
get him out mikasa then gets up close
and personal with ymir's horrifying
titan form and krista then tries to make
mikasa feel bad for ymir's situation and
tells ymir to not fight back but makusa
doesn't give two shits and is more than
willing to kill yamir right here and now
if she decides to turn against them
meanwhile the scouts try to get aired
out and make bertholdt feel bad about
betraying his own kind causing him to go
full-on crazy and says that someone
needs to spill blood for change to
happen making this guy one of the most
dangerous human beings alive right now
suddenly even more titans come from the
front and all of the scouts fall back
because all hell is about to break loose
the armored titan breaks through all of
the hungry titans as they try to eat the
humans on top of him the scouts are
shocked at the madness and even say is
this hell but commander irwin flies by
them on his horse leading a horde of
hungry titans to the armored titan yamir
and bertolt location he intends to use
the titan's bloodlust as a means of
distraction in order to free aaron
commander irwin orders his troops to
charge into what could be the very last
fight of their lives and just then a
titan comes in and eats his entire
armhole dragging him away while he
continues to give orders like a freaking
stud dozens of scouts get their flesh
eaten in seconds as they try to ride
through the sea of titans the armored
titan also finally uses his hands to get
the other titans off of him exposing
bertholdt and aaron and finally armin
manages to get under berthold's skin
saying that they're doing horrifying
experiments on annie as they speak
pissing off the two traitors to the core
and commander irwin shows up out of
nowhere half dead and frees aaron before
continuing his badassery and mikas and
the scouts run away also saving krista
in the process and making her realize
that ymir is lying to her about
everything but the armored titan and
anger starts throwing titans killing
more scouts in the distance and stabbing
mikasa and aaron dead in their tracks
and then they come across the same titan
that ate aaron's mother horrifying them
both to the bone okay this is some
harlem globetrotter slam dunk type
bullcrap these scouts it seems like they
don't have a brain who's the most
important person here aaron so why
didn't they provide him with any means
to protect himself when they first got
back they were clearly in possession of
some odm gear of which they could have
just given to him which would have made
him at least somewhat more
self-sufficient yet they chose not to
and now as predicted he's more of a
liability than an asset and this guy he
failed to save aaron's mother five years
ago to this very same titan there was
absolutely no reason for him to play the
hero card and instead of simply blocking
that titan hand and going for the home
run and taking this titan out all on his
own he should have taken advantage of
the situation and should have used that
split-second opportunity to save aaron
opting to swing him up to the nearby
trees rather than trying to fight this
titan head-on mikasa had her own gear
anyways and this guy knew that aaron was
the most important person to the mission
meaning this is one of those instances
where fleeing would have been the better
choice than fighting this guy i admire
his desire for revenge and redemption
but come on he let his emotions and hero
complex get the best of him and he paid
the ultimate price aaron quickly gets
freed by mikasa just as he watches one
of his dear friends get caught and
helplessly gets picked up he tries to
turn into a titan but nothing happens
forcing aaron to watch as his fellow
friend is eaten alive thanks to him yet
again being a useless piece of turd this
breaks aaron for a sec until mikasa
snaps him out of it boosting aaron's
confidence and he yells out and
unleashes a new power causing all titans
nearby to attack this titan and even
bertolt and rhina this is why these two
wanted to capture him because aaron has
something that can change everything the
scouts make a run for it and yamir even
switches saiza again and saves christa
before staying behind to hold off
bertolt and reina later the scouts find
out thanks to glasses girl that the
titans found at skinheads village appear
to be humans and residents of the
village itself meaning that these titans
could be in fact human elsewhere they
have no idea that outside of the wall
maria lies the beast titan and this guy
who has even more terrifying plans for
this city soon to come but what do you
think about attack on titan season 2 let
us know what you liked and what you
didn't like don't forget to subscribe
leave a thumbs up and as always don't
forget to check out our social media and
our how to be playlist